they were dry let them soak in water for
about an hour
then we have we have two kinds of arena
we will tellus with the arena people
zero that's Farina tell Serena of soft
meat means you can use all-purpose flour
and then we will make your party
Negreanu duro that's Sigma Nina flour we
have to sift it so it's in the u.s. it's
called the durum flour oh my god
so what are the proportions as we start
cooking so we Chinese dough Romney okay
this Farina pear persona so Seicento
what we will do we will make a change to
ground means the arena the ground corn
say fava it will be thicker the solid
this will be used to make a target area
and then we render using la Castagna or
la máquina de la pasta okay I won't show
you how to use it for the projector we
need a change to the Army 600 drums the
arena we want to process it so he comes
a little bit more fine at the moment
mrs. course pump it sicko salad and then
we just add a little bit of warm water
but you want the dough to be super super
hard so you don't want to add a lot of
water like we did with pizza or do with
other stuff okay just enough to put it
together and the idea is we want we need
to need to be able if you started for
for a long time okay so this is one
thing then what we're going to do today
or expected well be sonia levare esta
GRA equal Midori okay in medium in
Tortola gravida camera mozzarella aku
Bertie cubes
yes miss Katja no visual Oliveira in
but the eco mr. colleano - to CMS called
all you deliver a salad a possum or a
ginger in pecorino there are two Java
Havana what are we going to do that
through the tiny pellet sauce so these
are by far I'm so freaked up for your
opinion do you remember how to make
sofrito
it just means Elora then we can lower
the heat and add heavy cream and eat
salmon of famous lasagna that erected
several and I gotta say no no and you
want to really choppy the steel as you
better I forgot a couple these are
factory so to solid seems a lot of salt
right so you will have to ring some very
very very very well squeeze and then we
will add them to our mix
from